最近在上漲
可以說不用太擔心的關係是有一塊
叫做我們的AI一線均
他帶動指數往上走
而他們的本益比如果對應起
明年的成長性
超低 直立率都很棒
這個是一個
那另外我們發現現在資金又重新回到
青睞 PCB 上作下額都有
但是現在卻傳出 MSI 要納入的
載板類
因為分盤交易的關係
可能要暫緩
到底怎麼回事
這邊來請教維泰
每次都要來解讀這些
法說我們要變法會
然後為什麼會納入戰環
還有今天還要加碼一個
風策鼓
你覺得他就是一個
現在完全價值
還沒有被彰顯的產業
好 我們現在看一下今天
剛剛出爐的這個廣達
廣達
他在這個第二季的一個財報數字
我們先來跟大家來解讀一下
第二季營收是1.04兆
哇 兆華的兆
謝謝
計幀28.1% 年增105.6%
哇讚
毛利率大家會很關心
為什麼 因為他只有5.02%
比鴻海低
對 但是比毛三倒是要好
我們從哪個角度看
計幀0.24% 年減2.03%
然後再來稅後存異的部分
計幀35.2% 然後年增就19.9%
好 那麼這樣子的一個數字
我們可以看到就是
他在今年第二季的EPS
7.43元
ok
叫今年第一季是成長
因為今年第一季是5.5元
但是也叫去年第二季成長
因為去年第二季成長4.37元
我相信可能會有一些投資朋友
會認為說
哎呀毛利率5.02
這個叫去年還年減2.03%
以為這個是比較不好的消息
但是我們可以觀察到
因為營收年資率是一倍
超過100%的一個成長
所以使得他在整個營收
大幅度成長的情況之下
獲利也是大幅度的成長
所以我基本上認為
今天的廣達的數字來看
明天的股價應該是有機會
是往上去做走高的
好 那麼往上再做走高的過程當中
可能還有幾個關卡要去看
哪些關卡
第一個就是
這一波其實從這個地方往上反彈的一個過程當中
說實話其實
反彈的強度並不是特別的強
所以往上反彈可能第一個要先看到的這個地方
他在之前的後面這一段的一個孔方性賣壓
所造成的一個鐵套性賣壓
能不能夠去做一個克服
再來這邊還有一個所謂的一個除權席的這個
所謂的空貓缺孔
這兩個關卡應該都是接下來
當這個股價要往上去做反彈的時候
必須要去特別做關注的一個價量點
昨天華碩當然自然他的財報
非常亮麗是個歷史新高的狀態
然後三率也三升
但是他也順便有籌資
市場就不是很在意他的籌資
還是直接一價就漲停上去
廣達的籌資讓他是吃跌停
這個事情應該要還他吧
對好
所以我覺得接下來大家可能就會
觀察到他在接下來的這種屬於股價
針對這樣子的一個法書
或者數字來看的話
是不是有機會緩大公道
OK 那麼廣達我們
把它歸納在這個老AI
那我們來幫大家來看一下
現在的老AI的一個族群
但實際上老AI的族群
我們叫做AI伺服器的一個組裝
其實AI伺服器組裝的領域
好像的族群有稍微擴大了
在這個去年
我們大概是講說
這個老鴨大概就是三雄鼎力
或者是四雄鼎力
但是今年在做
AIS伺服器相關的隔骨來講
變多了
包括像是技嘉 音樂達
神達 合塑 人寶跟華塑等等
ok 好
那我們在這些的所謂的一個
這個AIS伺服器的一個
這個組裝隔骨當中
特別觀察到
有一些的這個EPS已經公告出來了
例如說剛提到了像是鴻海
廣達
好像微影等等
他們這些過去的
所謂的一個老AI的一個三雄
他們在今年上半年的
EPS的成長幅度
好點37%
這樣剛剛的廣達
然後這個鴻海大概只有25%左右而已
但是其實一些新出來的
包括像是這個音樂達
今年上半年的EPS的成長幅度
是61.47%
那麼甚至這個人寶
還交出了93.44%的一個好成雞丹
我想這個四出必有因
這個空穴不來風
他們會有這樣子
EPS大幅度成長
一定跟他的基本沒有關
不過他們如果進來的話
會不會對於就所謂的
毛利率廝殺又要展開一波的競爭
因為這一波的話
鴻海昨天的毛利率
沒有就是第一點點
大家就會有一點點懷疑了
是的 對
我個人覺得這個訂單的分散
可能會發生
但是如果說從這個各大協職批業者
他們還是在持續的在這個資本支出的情況下
我覺得其實影響性應該不會太大
因為資本支出這麼大
總是大家要分得做
那我們來看一下這麼多個股裡面
現在看一下剛所提到
就是比較屬於新進挑戰者的
例如說像2376的技嘉
很強耶
有沒有發現到他們這些新進挑戰者
不管是技嘉或者是音樂打
他們的股價表現股價的形態
就跟廣達跟紅矮不太一樣
他們是這一波拉回
基本上連這個半年間都沒有碰到
就往上再做走高
那這是拉回來的過程當中
其實可以觀察到大陸持股的部分
其實是沒有出現鬆動的
甚至還在持續往上再做一個增溫
反倒是這個過程當中散戶
有一點點這個持股去出現這個減少
各式計劃
再來這個是2356殷夜達
特別觀察到這波拉軌
大概就回測到基建附近
那麼大陸之谷的部分
也是持續往上增加的
那麼小陸之谷是在那邊做減少的
那麼接下來他在整個
所謂的美國的休斯頓廠
他要擴充L10跟L11的
高階系統組裝
所以對他們在接下來
Q3跟Q4他的營收的成長
應該是可以值得期待
因為他們之前
其實也是有表態過
技嘉好厲害
他快要回到這個高點區了
前波段表態大概就是因為他們已經知道
他要去切入這個從L6
切入到L10跟L11
那麼下一檔是大家可能比較沒有注意到的
就是合塑
是 我跟委太剛也有消透論
因為他之前的獲利狀況真的不理想
就本業不理想
對 但是合塑我想他在最近這幾年
也一直在去尋找這個轉型的一個方向
那麼終於被他找到了
被他找到了
公司預估今年
哇似乎去營收
會出現十倍數爆發
機器低啦
對啦
目標朝向千億元規模賣勁
但重點是
他不是只有家做L6
他就直接切到這個
這個所謂高單價
所有人貴的整個
也就是L11的相關的業務
所以使得他在這一次的股價表現
跟剛剛的技嘉音樂達一樣
讓他回擊並沒有碰到半連線
在一個技嘉附近
就量說就做個打底
那麼今天網上出現
開高走高
有創造漲停
對 盤中是有來到
漲停版的價位
但是是漲停版沒有所住
那很正常
為什麼人家買在這邊等多久
等一個月 兩個月 兩個半月時間
所以拉上來可以做忽略了結
對不對
所以呢 明天跟後天
特別觀察到
有沒有辦法去針對
今天的上影線做修正
如果上影線你能夠做修正的話
哇 那個亮先駕行
亮先駕行
所以接下來的前波的高點
應該就是有機會去做個挑戰
今天那也是想要挑戰一下
但是就有壓力了
是的 好
這個是在這個核輸的部分
那剛才這個趙懷也問到
就是MSCI這個傳緊急公告
對 緊急公告
到底有多緊急
多緊急
也差一天而已
不是嗎
好 可是我們改成兩分鐘了耶
他還是一個影響啊
總是這是一個處置期間
大家這個交易的一個過程當中
可能會有點卡卡的
所以因為這個消息本來
早上傳出來被納入的那這些個股
早上開高之後就出現震盪
出現震盪
但是這樣子震盪對我們投資人來講
到底是好事還是壞事
是不是能夠因為這樣子的一個
緊急公告呢
讓股下能夠有機會跌低點
那我們進場去做一個切入呢
我們來看一下他的整個的一個基本面的表現
我們還是回到財報上啦
對
好 我們現在看一下剛剛的台藥
台藥 台藥還有剛剛另外一檔
是這個錦塑
台藥跟錦塑
他們在今年累計的EPS的YOLY
台藥成長百分之162
很好
三位數
錦塑也不差163.43
兩檔差不多
對 所以在整個EPS成長的這個
這個角度來看
基本上他們都大幅度成長
所以我覺得即便是有剛剛
我們這種所謂的就是
戰管納入的消息
我倒覺得其實也不至於說
股價會持續性的下跌
那麼如果說就像這個
仔板來看好了
本益比比較低的大概就整頂
整頂可以玩
他現在的這個本益比呢
大概就35倍
ok 這個是整頂
那至於PCB的部分來講
其實本益比有的高有的低
有的高有的低
那我們來挑一檔
就是拉回幅度比較深的
而且有滑的
有滑的
是這樣子是不是
好的
好 我們來看一下
好
這個是 4958 的真頂
很多生活朋友有關心他
因為他的價位
可能是目前四雄比較低的
法說會好像講的沒有很積極
所以似乎有點橫盤整理
過去其實真頂
被大家所討論就是
因為他什麼都做
軟板也有 硬板也有
HDI 板也有
然後反而最近的 IC 載板
前一陣子
大家都在炒他的比重比較低
比較低嘛
那麼後來他有在做擴散
擴散之後主要是針對這個
高速的光模組的部分去做個切入
所以大家對他重新去做個評價
那麼短期三本來講
這邊往上拉高的擴散當中
碰到是月線的反壓
那我想說真理完成之後
應該是有機會再往上去做重高
他之前也有傳出
就是跟輝達之間有一個
HDI版的消息
公司還特地出來澄清
所以他最近是比較多雜音
是的
那麼再來是2313的滑通
滑通也是壓力有點小小大
他從305塊跌到150
對啊
這個是腰斬
所以這個地方他回到就是半年線位置
那麼相較於這個整頂
他這一波往上拉高
他是有突破月線的
所以能夠突破月線拉回
基本上我覺得他落底的機會
是相當相當的大
OK 那大陸持久部
在最近這一周有出現比較明顯的增加
這個是滑通
他來到他線增加的附近
看能不能讓
參與憲政的人賺多一點
對
好 再來還有一個族權
就財報數字不錯
然後呢
前陣子呢
股價也做拉軌
就是這個封測
封測
封測你看
我都配合幫他找出
聯計一PS專位數成長
是
然後聯計營收歪歪大於零的
ok 這些個股都相當相當的忌憂
而且呢
除了營收成長之外
基本上他們本益比
除了這一個金財
他本益比是50多倍之外
基本上大家都在11
10倍 20倍左右的這樣子的一個本益比的一個區間
那我們一樣幫大家挑一個價格比較低的
本益比比較低的
哎呀 也有一個滑
真好
你是臨時響的吧
來看一下2329的滑胎
美超為感恩股
不要忘記昨天美超為是大招
沒錯 他這個大肌晚體嗎
不知道 反正美超為這個財報不錯
那麼滑胎呢又是這個美超為
他在這個伺服器
主機板相關的這個所謂的供應商
供應合作夥伴
而且他還有這個
切入到AI儲存
跟快閃機體的控制IC的
控制機能變得豐妝
那這個波段拉回到這個地方
哇 總六十幾塊
跌到三十七塊
簡直基本上
拉回的幅度也減低百分之五十
那麼近期呢
大陸之谷已經有開始出現
往上再做翻揚的情況
那反而閃負這邊開始去做一個退場
所以我覺得像這樣子的個股呢
因為跌深嘛
再加上有一些這個題材的加持
所以接下來拉回可以特別做留意
因為我們之前可能比較常講到
什麼日日光系格等等的
華泰我們好久沒關注了
算是一個低價位的選擇
沒錯
這邊非常謝謝維泰
謝謝大家